babe let's go out to eat what are you in
the mood for puffins
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well good morning everybody we made it
to Iceland yay thank you hanging in
there
we gotta go get checked into our rental
house and I gotta remember how to drive
a manual
it's a Dacia duster we're gonna stall it
we're gonna install it no no stalling
it's like falling off a bicycle I'm
assuming the orange sign that says 30 is
the speed limit right we're not driving
into traffic right I really should have
Googled this before I came here
entire neighborhood looks like it was
bought at IKEA
all right
it's a pretty spot
yeah look at this it's like 40 degrees
outside they've left all the windows
open you know so it doesn't get too hot
in here
I'll tell you what we're pretty pleased
with this rental there wasn't a lot of
options on the market and some of them
were really weird there were rentals
that came with people's pets in the
rental all right hopefully I brought the
right adapter we're gonna see if I get
electrocuted here
oh
that shot Sparks out that seems to be
working
all right let's go get some breakfast
all righty I say we go into Ricky pick
and get some breakfast
pork belly pickled coleslaw beetroot
sorry they just let me know no no we got
sausage and eggs and some sort of tomato
sauce
avocado on toast oh that looks good
Tommy you're alive
[Music]
you know what they say if you can't
sleep eat
I'm gonna put a link down in the video
description all the different things we
do including the sandholt restaurant
oh reindeer pelts Becca how many
reindeer pelts is too many reindeer
pelts how many do you have four
you look at my easy
oh look I definitely don't need more
Icelandic sheepskin pelts oh a dancing
polar bear
me and Becca have a tradition that
anytime we go to a foreign country we
buy a kids book from that country and we
try to get a kids book That's Unique to
that country so there we go you want a
hot water bottle yeah
oh how you guys doing you tired yes
oh we were all so exhausted we got back
to the house Becca went down for a nap
and I swore I was gonna try to stay
awake
yeah I didn't work
oh
you ready to snorkel the coldest water
in the world
I don't know I hope so
right now we're driving to Silver where
Becca is going to do some of the coldest
snorkeling on the face of the Earth and
to get there we're gonna drive on the
Golden Ring which is one of the many
extremely scenic drives around Reykjavik
you guys fall asleep
oh
um
so Becca's got her dry suit on and she's
gonna go diving in some 34 degree water
the only way you can get colder is if
you cut a hole through the ice well the
reason why Becca is braving this
bitterly cold water is because silphra
is where two continental tectonic plates
meet North America and Europe are
together slowly spreading apart and she
is going to dive the crack between the
two
see this crack right here
this is where two continents meet
you're looking good babe
okay it's impossible to drop
oh that looks cold there's just a little
bit of current in this crack so Becca
and her group are just gonna float with
the current for about 30 minutes or so I
gave Becca a GoPro before I set her off
I'm curious to see the footage
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was beautiful it was beautiful
awesome do you get cold yes we got a
cold I had in my hands the rest was
really good actually was it worth it
though yes I'm so glad I did it here
oh amazing you get get your warmer yeah
yeah I love the hot water bottles
this area where Becca Dove is part of a
national park and there's tons of
historical geological and just beautiful
things to see here and as always we're
gonna put a link in the video
description to sell for below so you can
check this out as well
oh look at that waterfall up there okay
we gotta do a little bit of a hike don't
we Becca yeah see this Cliff right here
this is the edge of the North American
tectonic plate so we're standing on
Europe
that's North America
that's cool
now my Icelandic is no bueno but I think
that waterfall is called oxurorifas
hey Jacob have you ever heard of the
Icelandic pickle spiders
no oh no an Icelandic tickle spider
let's go get some food okay
then we got like a swarmapita that one's
Falafel some spices and ketchup and Mayo
on these fries
hmm I'm glad this worked out the entire
menu was in Icelandic after being so
cold does that flawful hit the spot it's
good yeah
all right
well we're back at the rental property
and the kids are getting put down to bed
I'm gonna go run to the grocery store
and pick up supplies make sure we have
something to eat for breakfast tomorrow
morning all right this grocery store is
called Neato parnetto I don't know
yeah grassling red currant some sort of
Crepes oh Becca would love that
oh these are little Icelandic Donuts
I don't know what this is but I think I
should buy it I gotta buy that for
science
I think that's granola I don't know what
traditionally goes on these little crepe
things but I think yogurt would go well
creme brulee yogurt oh man oh dried
cured fish here
as an Alaskan I'll tell you that is a
fine selection of smoked salmon they got
going on here some sort of baked potato
maybe that pickled cabbage yeah we'll
try that some sort of candy give that a
go
foreign
I bought way too much junk food but uh
We're not gonna starve I've been really
impressed with how many icelanders speak
fluent English I expected that I'd have
to struggle my way through at least a
little bit of Icelandic but uh so far
everybody I've met has just been fluent
really impressive we'll get the food put
away and it's getting late I'm gonna go
to bed I'm gonna see you guys in the
morning oh good morning oh we went to
bed so early last night slept about nine
and a half hours and I am still so tired
but uh you know it's a beautiful day we
got a lot plans so we're gonna get some
breakfast going and we're gonna get the
kids up all right we have the uvar's
flat cookur or crepey thingies I think
there's a cup of coffee spreading maybe
some butter on it and it looks like a
leg of ham or something we're gonna
pretend they're Crepes listen I don't
want to give you the impression that I
know what I'm doing here I'm just
running around Iceland grabbing things
that look tasty and giving it a try I
hmm
here hey Dad what type of tips
all right guys it's seven degrees
Celsius outside who wants to go swimming
[Music]
oh there's going to be warm but it's
going to be cold outside
go ahead get on in can you throw up
[Music]
okay this is nice this is a nice
temperature is it hi guys welcome to the
Blue Lagoon this is a volcanic hot
spring here in Iceland it did you like
this yeah
it's fun yeah it's the perfect
temperature
it's like a very nice bath temperature
most places but every once in a while
though there'd be this little warm spot
of really hot water
yeah
it's cool over here
my glasses are getting a little hard to
see through
this makes me look so much older first
place I've ever
discarded their wearing ski jackets
it's cold out over there got a little
beef didn't it oh yeah
oh that's hot all right Nathan let's go
to the steam room
there's the steam room
what do you guys think is this Stevie
yes do you like that
oh
it's so cold now guys do you want to try
a sauna
yeah you might like to throw in a better
Nate come on
this is this is the sauna
yeah this is sauna
yeah
yeah if you didn't like the steam then
the sun is for you
it's okay you want to get a mud facial
thank you yeah your war paint
guys do we feel beautiful yet okay
Tommy you look four years old your skin
is so glowing Nathan Nathan you look
like two years younger
thank you
have you guys though no okay okay okay
our steam rooms your new favorite thing
yes Nathan's just over in the sauna
chatting up everybody in his water wings
Jacob are you having fun
Becca are you having a good time I'm
having a great day Tommy's getting
pretty wrinkly though
[Applause]
[Music]
and we gotta return our bracelets this
is what you use to open your locker and
do a lot of things you can also charge
things to your card on the bracelet you
just pay on your way out
bandic food here at Cafe Loki and if
we're lucky we might even get to eat
fermented shark meat foreign
ammonia smell shark's blood is full of
ammonia
that is a really complex flavor it
starts off tasting a little bit like
smoked bacon or something and then all
of a sudden it has this like ammonia
feeling goes up through your nose and
then it has this fishy aftertaste it's
it's a wild ride this is dried fish
right here we're gonna try dried fish
and butter we've got a little uh dried
fish on flatbread with a little bit of
butter
that's actually good it's not fishy at
all do you like the smoked lamb
that's really good lamb shank
you like the dried fish
[Music]
well after that lovely lunch we're gonna
walk around town a little bit
but uh right here by the church is the
Iglesia
how's that for attempting an Icelandic
pronunciation
smelling inside
Icelandic husky socks see look how warm
those are
I'm gonna wear these socks
you need that Tommy is that what you
need yeah
all right I think we need to get this
oh look there's no puppets what should
we name it you gotta call him Puff Daddy
Reykjavik really is a low-key City it's
got all the little shops and fun things
but it's not busy it's not crazy
would you like to wear that
look at sharp there Jake it's the Museum
of Icelandic Punk
it's like the Ramones but with more
puffins
well we've been walking around and doing
a bit of shopping here in Reykjavik but
Becca's all tired so I'm gonna go get
the car come back and pick her up so
Becca you like having your private
chauffeur come pick you up it was great
there's something I've wanted to do in
Iceland for a little bit and that is eat
some Puffin so we're gonna go to a
restaurant that serves cooked puffin
okay guys we're at the Hereford
Steakhouse here in Reykjavik and uh
we're gonna be trying Puffin and whale
they also have horse steak here but
unfortunately I can only eat so much in
one city I've actually had raw horse
before it was pretty good all right guys
my appetizer showed up we've got
ourselves some smoked Puffin this is the
Puffin Fork so it's the Puffin Forks
always on the outside
I like them here babe you want to try
some puffin
tastes a little bit like bacon a little
bit it's got a smoky flavor it's really
nice A little raspberry sauce
right there
what do you think they actually have a
puffin hunting season here in Iceland
and people go and hunt them with
long-handled Nets they scoop them up
from the cliff tops
yeah what type of whale is that there we
go guys that's a whale steak
all right we're gonna try the whale seat
tastes like beef
's tender but lean steak there you go
babe
it does taste like beef steak doesn't it
I think the only difference between this
and a normal steak you get is this is a
lot leaner there's no Grizzle on it it's
got a little bit more of that gamey
flavor or that a lean steak has but it's
good
check it out this is skid it's an
Icelandic dessert it's kind of like a
thick yogurt and there's some sorbet on
top
well that's good
the sorbet is kind of Tangy and the
skeeter is kind of creamy like yogurt
hey boys you like your banana split yeah
that's amazing I'll tell you what I kind
of came here for the novelty of the
Puffin and the whale but it was really
really good we'd eat here again in a
heartbeat but like always we'll put
links in the video description below to
all the things we do in this video it's
really nice they gave the free ice cream
here in Iceland they don't do a lot of
tipping but you know the service is
really good so occasionally I'll do a
very small tip but I got my math a
little confused I ended up giving the
guy a 70 tip instead of a seven dollar
tip
they were really excited I decided to
play it cool like I'm a high roller not
just some dude that's really bad at math
we had a lot of things planned today
that didn't happen we had a spear
fishing charter that got canceled we
were supposed to go to a video game
Museum that was closed so today was a
day of just playing it by ear and it
turned out really well but we were tired
and we're gonna go to bed and I'll see
you guys bright and early tomorrow
we're going fishing tomorrow and I'm
really excited well good morning guys
it's a lovely day here in Iceland and
I'm running off to the bakery to get us
some food to take on our fishing trip
all right
good morning
Reykjavik sea adventures and we're gonna
do a little fishing charter it is
absolutely a beautiful day
[Music]
you ready to catch a fish no
pay attention pay attention
oh there's a fish yeah it fits on here
oh
look at that
oh Hey Jake
[Music]
we've been here less than two minutes
and Nathan's got one on the deck and
Tommy's reeling another one in
yeah that looks like that looks like
what we we call it Tomcat in Alaska from
your gate
you might have the biggest fish
[Music]
Jake look at your gun
that's a big Cod
oh look at the color on that oh that's
Todd the Cod
oh there he is there he is
a little little we're just drifting over
the top of an underwater hump we'll hit
it a few times and the boat will drift
off the spot we reposition do it again
[Music]
oh you got one there Jake yeah you got a
little haddock here
yeah look at that you want to be friends
oh I think that's the bigger headache
maybe
look at that pretty thing yeah nice
brown brown truck send him back oh
no We're Just Fishing a few minutes
outside of the bay here at Reykjavik so
it's nice and close didn't have to do a
big jog out into the ocean not too
expensive not a big time commitment
yeah you gotta get that fish look at
that a double
oh these are just little guys
can you imagine I threw them back
someone's angry at dad for throwing his
fish in the water it's a big brownie big
brownie kindergarten you want to go back
to kindergarten see you like those
not a bad boat snack huh
as many or as
a dove oh my goodness mom
look at this
double Cod congratulations Becca
oh guys I got a fish
have a
yeah yeah there you go
there you go nice
there you go
[Music]
look at the teeth on these cards don't
put your hands in there all right get
them Nate get them it's a beast hey look
how big that's the biggest one
oh
no Oreo
nice card
he's a little bit small
there's a bunch of Seagulls following
the boat and the boys have named each
and every one of them
oh
a couple nice card
well we haven't been at this for very
long but we have more than enough fish I
think it's time to go back and Grill
some up look at all this fish
[Music]
we're gonna take advantage of this
lovely weather and Grill up some fish
here
Where Are You by getting sunburned yeah
I know
I'm so down
oh wow
look at that I got potatoes fresh Cod
veggies
you know this is not too bad sitting on
a boat in a beautiful day eating fresh
fish
I could do this more often well Becca
Are you full
hey thank you very much
pleasure thank you
it's a lovely day today but everyone's a
little tired so we're just gonna do some
driving around and see some of the
gorgeous scenery here on the island
all right let's eat the giant Rice
Krispie Treat
oh
it's like cake
oh wow look at that
that was that cake thing was actually
Wicked awesome
we got a bunch of Icelandic cowgirls and
cowboys driving horses down the highway
got a little traffic jam here
that was legitimate Icelandic cowboy in
right there
all right we're gonna check out one of
Iceland's many black sand beaches this
one's called red [ __ ]
so these Columns of rock are made of
Basalt which is formed when lava cools
really quickly and these are the same
type of rock formations that we saw in
Scotland and in Northern Ireland at the
Giant's Causeway
do they look familiar
apparently this is a popular spot to do
wedding photos
I'll tell you why this is a gorgeous
Beach and a perfect place to do our
thumbnail luckily I brought along Puff
Daddy
one two three say cheese I'm trying to
shoot this thumbnail and every time I
turn my back some tourists yell puff it
and run up and try to take photos of it
it's actually really funny
all right we've had our fun time to put
Puff Daddy back in the box
this place is so beautiful but it's also
so popular at this very moment I see two
wedding photographers three drones and a
lot of people
I think we're gonna get some dinner here
oh thank you I'll tell you what I love
eating lamb we don't get it enough in
the U.S
should we go see some waterfalls yeah
sure anybody want to try one look at
these things
like a popcorn ball
s
yeah
then you go you go back to Mama
oh there's a girl
three three
yeah I'm wet
we got protesters
fight the power apparently there's a
hiking trail up to the top of the
waterfall but uh
I'm wet I'm going in the car
look at that thing
Becca and the kids are pretty tired so
she sent me up here to check out this
waterfall real quick
that is the coolest waterfall I've ever
been to I gotta go get back and let her
have a turn she's got to see this
Rebecca you should go see it it's way
cool
Becca what'd you think that was so worth
it that was so cool
well good morning it is a beautiful
Sunday and uh we're gonna walk down the
street to the church
so by pure coincidence our rental
property's like a three minute walk from
the church so we're going for a little
Sunday stroll
well guys I think it's time to put the
camera up I'll see you in a little bit
baby well church was pretty interesting
the service was in Icelandic Spanish and
English yeah it was a very International
congregation but but did you have a good
time I did yeah it was excellent all
right now the church now we're gonna do
a little bit of driving and I need to
get lunch ready
foreign
give that about 30 minutes to an hour it
should be perfect well it is a gorgeous
day here in Iceland so we're going to
get out of Reykjavik and try to see more
of the gorgeous Countryside including
some waterfalls and maybe even a geyser
look we're parked right here in front of
the geyser sounds like a wonderful place
to eat some food how about that a little
picnic
all righty yours no ketchup right
[Music]
okay
they called him
ship
smoked salmon locks wrapped in the
little crepey thing
that's good
season potatoes with us not bad
huh no pickup we're gonna try this thing
for dessert looks like a oatmeal based
Rice Krispie Treat or something you know
what reminds me of those no bake cookies
not peanut butter all right guys let's
go check out a geyser the name of this
place is geyser spelled
g-e-y-s-i-r and all the other geysers in
the world are named after this this is
where the word geyser comes from so this
is one of the main geysers here at
geyser and it goes off sporadically so
you kind of just gotta wait and see but
it gets up there pretty high
whoa
oh
you think of that
well that was pretty cool it seems to go
off about every five minutes or so but
it's it's pretty sporadic
look at that you can see the boiling
water in there Jake
it's just like gurgling
oh
and it's the right thing remember
oh you can but I don't know look there's
people driving around in utvs
how would you like to do that
yeah how cool is that huh
thank you
[Music]
maybe that was fun that was fun glad
that worked out well good morning guys
me and Tommy are going out to go get
some breakfast for the family
oh my goodness look at that thing
that looks good that looks way good
nothing's bigger than your head
[Music]
yeah
so good still good
look at that that oh it is so gooey try
this one
oh oh that's good that's delicious
oh this was good I'm gonna put this
Bakery in the video description if you
guys think is that is that the best
bakery stuff you've had on this trip
yeah all right we're just packing up and
checking out and unfortunately we're
going to have to leave Puff Daddy here
in Iceland apparently it's illegal to
bring puffins into the United States
Taxidermy or otherwise but I think he'll
be at home here with the other Taxidermy
Birds
foreign
[Music]
well guys did you have a fun time yeah
yeah listen I hope you guys enjoyed
watching this video as much as we
enjoyed filming it if you guys want to
see more travel Adventure videos from
the outdoor Boys YouTube channel make
sure to check out our travel Adventure
video playlist and we put out new videos
every Saturday morning so don't forget
to click subscribe
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]